[Musique]
notre voyage est bien plus important que
le nine faire l'humanité n'a encore
jamais eu l'opportunité ni les moyens
d'établir un premier contact
si nous
si nous tous réussissons cette mission
l'histoire sera réécrite
écoutez notre planète va mourir et le
nightfire est notre unique chance
d'entrer en contact avec un level
créneau exploite une énergie qui est
1000 fois supérieur à tout ce que vous
pouvez imaginer
et s'il nous aide à comprendre ce que
c'est peut-être qu'on pouvoir arriver à
sauver notre planète a sauvé deux fois
une erreur dans les codes chef
dysfonctionnement sur le thème
quand chez nous
[Musique]
quelqu'un est entré dans le système
je ne peux pas trouver les codes du
programme d'habitat des risques on a un
problème
ces dysfonctionnements ne font que
retarder notre cause qu'est-ce qui va
pas quelque chose a pris le contrôle une
entité essaient de saboter cette mission
il y avait quelque chose
la barre
ils sont certes mais s'ouvrir
et
reviendra pas sans avoir établi un
contact
contrôlez pas ce qui se passe
c'est le baril scarione
il ne veut pas qu'on effectue ce qu'ils
y ont
hu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]